The space shuttle Endeavour left the Earth for the last time Monday,...
...blasting off from the Kennedy Space Center in Florida.
Four, three, two, one, zero... and liftoff for the final launch of Endeavour,...
...expanding our knowledge and expanding our lives in space.
The youngest shuttle in NASA's fleet is heading toward the International Space Station.
It will deliver spare parts to the orbiting laboratory...
...along with an instrument that will help astronomers study the formation of the universe.
Six astronauts, including one from Italy, are onboard Endeavour.
The mission commander is astronaut Mark Kelly.
Shortly before launch, he shared a few words with Mission Control:...
"This mission represents the power of teamwork, commitment, and exploration."
"It is in the DNA of our great country to reach for the stars and explore."
"We must not stop."
Among the estimated half million spectators of the liftoff was Kelly's wife,...
...US Representative Gabrielle Giffords.
She was wounded during a shooting rampage in Arizona in January.
After liftoff, shuttle launch Director Mike Leinbach spoke to reporters:...
"Endeavour is on orbit safely,..."
"...and is gonna perform a great mission, and we'll see her back here on June first."